maison de voisinage des coudraet à MPa
dernière réunion de préparation pour ces
bénévoles de la Croix-Rouge dernière
consigne d'organisation une halpie pour
les malades d'Alzheimer se met en place
tous les samedis après-midi pendant au
maximum 4h les malades peuvent être reçu
ici différentes activités leur sont
proposées ça va être fonction de de de
l'accueillli en fonction de de ses
capacités à pouvoir participer à un jeu
ou pas ses capacités physique il va
falloir qu'on s'adapte c'est pour ça que
nos nos bénévoles ont eu des formations
très précises sur la maladie d'Alzheimer
et pour le que nous ferons des des la
formation continue systématique les
bénévoles ont été formés par France
Alzheimer une psychologue de France
Alzheimer et le suivi de la formation
sera fait ensuite par Lyon szheimer on
apprend comment les recevoir comment
s'occuper
d'eux si s'ils aiment la musique s'ils
aiment pas la musique si
savoir tout ce qu'il sont un petit peu
oublié parmi ces bénévoles Françoise
elle officie aussi déjà au sein de la
Croix-Rouge et prend son rôle très à
cœur je suis quelqu'un qui est qui qui
est là qui aime rendre service aux
autres j'ai besoin en 6 mois de bah
d'être utile on va dire la al répie
Alzheimer de la Croix-Rouge fonctionne
tous les samedis après-midi quatre
malades au maximum y sont reçus les
familles qui souhaitent bénéficier de ce
service doivent prendre au préalable
afin de constituer un dossier qui permet
de connaître les habitudes des malades
une participation financière est
demandée elle est minime 5
€